it's really hard watching my son get out
there in the cage and fight I I get more
nervous for his fights than I am mine
I'm very proud of my my son whatever the
outcome would be because I know how hard
it is and how much work it takes to get
in there getting it just to do it and
you know I felt very confident him
fighting with uh UFL because I'm with
the UFL and um I think that if I'm gonna
be honest again I can protect him more
early in his career like pick the right
fights for him you know I know it's a
lot of people wouldn't really say that
but I just gotta keep it real you know
it's my my son so you know he's 0-0 is a
professional right he just turned Pro so
I'm not going to put him in there with a
with a fighter that's got 15 fights you
shouldn't do that to anybody but it's
been done a lot in my profession man
because people don't really love that
fighter this this is a fighter that I
love he came from my balls
so you know I'ma put him in there with
somebody that got close to the same
experience as he does